[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
de reporteros el documental de france a
24 si río blanco como siempre un gusto
saludarlos hoy por ángela gutiérrez el
presidente de eeuu joe biden se ha
comprometido a retirar las tropas
estadounidenses de afganistán antes del
11 de septiembre como resultado otras
naciones occidentales también están
reduciendo y retirando sus fuerzas el
escenario está listo para el regreso de
los talibanes 20 años después de haber
sido derrocados por una coalición
militar liderada por washington a raíz
de los ataques del 11 de septiembre en
nueva york
en este reporteros las corresponsales de
france 24 margo ven y sol en salvo no
fioriti nos muestran una mirada en
profundidad al gobierno del grupo
talibán con sus escuelas y el tribunal
de justicia un anticipo de la vida
cotidiana bajo los fundamentalistas
islámicos veamos
[Música]
provincia de herat en el occidente de
afganistán
pasamos frente a la última base del
ejército afgano y campamento
atrincherado de donde los soldados no
salen casi nunca
más allá se encuentra una tierra de
nadie' que se disputan diferentes grupos
armados
tras meses de negociaciones se pudimos
reunirnos con importantes comandantes
del grupo talibán en algún lugar de esta
pista aislada
a nuestro lado hay un traductor y una
escolta armada
hay muchos explosivos accionables a
distancia en esta carretera pero no tema
no los harán explotar
aparte de nosotros nadie puede venir a
esta zona o abandonarla los talibán nos
esperan en este desierto donde se
escuchan disparos de armas automáticas a
lo lejos
y estos hombres son muy conservadores
creo que deben ponerse en sus burkas
estos combatientes exigieron reunirse
con nosotros en esta zona neutra en las
fronteras de su zona de influencia
[Música]
para esta ocasión plantaron la bandera
talibán
el comandante nos esperara allá la
entrevista sólo dura unos cuantos
minutos estas no son buenas condiciones
para hablar normalmente permanecemos en
las montañas bajamos por esteros por lo
general no nos sentamos así al aire
libre
estos combatientes fueron desplegados en
la región desde hace algunos días en
afganistán por todas partes en la
guerrilla fundamentalista extiende su
dominio y multiplica sus ataques en
especial cerca de las grandes ciudades
esperamos muchos refuerzos nuestras
posibilidades serán 200 ayer estamos
rodeando la provincia de herat y
esperamos orden recibimos la orden de
capturar la ciudad varias y cuando
llegamos a un pueblo nos instalamos en
la mezquita donde dormimos
lo primero que hacemos es cerrar las
escuelas porque basan su trabajo en el
programa escolar se convierte macana
destruimos las escuelas y despedimos a
todos los profesores y otros empleados
en su lugar instalamos nuestras propias
escuelas religiosas de as para la madre
trabajan con nuestro programa informan
talibán
valdés co
tras esta entrevista a las autoridades
talibán nos autorizan a grabar un pueblo
bajo su control
su objetivo es convencernos de que el
movimiento no es tan solo una fuerza
militar sino también una alternativa
creíble al gobierno oficial para
nosotros es una forma de descubrir este
estado paralelo que bien podría si los
talibán acceden al poder prefigurar el
afganistán del mañana
y hagan su reportaje pero si vemos
vehículos del gobierno ingresar a
nuestro pueblo así ustedes estén
atacaremos
suficiente con frecuencia hay drones que
sobrevuelan esta zona no podemos
permanecer más tiempo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los combates entre soldados afganos y
los talibán causan estragos por todas
partes fueron apartados del poder hace
20 años por una coalición militar
liderada por eeuu
pero la guerrilla fundamentalista está
ganando terreno
y mientras las fuerzas internacionales
se están retirando de manera definitiva
el ejército afgano exhausto no tiene la
capacidad de contener su avance
a los talibán ya controlarían más de la
mitad del territorio hoy son los amos de
las zonas rurales
áreas que no se beneficiaron de los más
de 150 mil millones de dólares de ayuda
para el desarrollo entregados por la
comunidad internacional fondos desviados
en parte por las élites y con frecuencia
dirigidos a las ciudades
[Música]
emblemas de modernidad para unos
símbolos de derroche para otros las
ciudades conforman el último bastión del
estado afgano contra los insurgentes
islas de libertad donde los citadinos
disfrutan de los placeres prescritos
bajo el régimen talibán
tales como cortarse la barba
deambular entre chicas
[Aplausos]
bailar durante los matrimonios
o elevar una cometa
[Música]
libertades que los rebeldes muy cerca de
las metrópolis podrían hacer desaparecer
de nuevo
si las negociaciones actuales con el
gobierno desembocan en una división del
poder los talibán podrían lograr su
cometido
reinstalar a través del país un régimen
islamista ultra conservador
a menos de dos horas en carro de la
capital llegamos al valle de omar jair
en el corazón de la provincia de wardak
en la carretera de los combatientes nos
escolta en el motor
encargados de garantizar nuestra
seguridad nos vigilan durante toda la
grabación
[Música]
en el pueblo nos acoge el patriarca
najibullah sediqi una figura respetada
de la región es uno de los pocos que nos
abrió su puerta
20 años de presencia extranjera
alimentaron una gran desconfianza frente
a los occidentales
como cada mañana su hija sign up de 10
años se ocupa de los pozos
la casa no cuenta con agua potable
la familia siempre ha vivido en este
pueblo controlado por los talibán desde
hace 12 años
cada mañana recojo agua
voy a la escuela
pues ya está
[Música]
jarmusch quiero que estudie las
lecciones desde la mañana deja eso yo me
encargo ocúpate más bien de estudiar en
la escuela de acuerdo si estudias
juiciosa de comprar libros y lápices
para la mona hoy hay un out
aquí no hay escuela del gobierno los
fundamentalistas abrieron una escuela
para hombres que enseñan programas
talibanes en cuanto a las mujeres esta
casa frente a la cual patrullan hombres
armados acoge a las alumnas es una de
las promesas de los insurgentes si
regresan al poder dejar que las niñas
sigan estudiando por lo menos hasta el
final de la primaria una forma para
ellos de tranquilizar a la comunidad
internacional
[Música]
en omar jair un habitante del pueblo es
quien dicta clases frente a la cámara la
profesora debe esconder su rostro
traduce el corán del árabe el bastón la
lengua hablada en verdad
el corán hay numerosas palabras para
describir a dios para decir lo poderoso
que es que estamos en casa en la calle
por todas partes la religión es la
materia principal para este único grupo
que acoge niñas de todas las edades en
cuantos años el santo corán fue revelado
en la tierra en 23 años y a quien fue
enviado al santo profeta mahoma y quien
le llevó el corán al respecto gabriel
dama atrás necesitamos una verdadera
escuela coránica ayúdenos construir una
parte memorizar el corán entero
tengo muchos alumnos son inteligentes y
aprenden muy bien sus lecciones mi clase
de religión dura cuatro horas al día los
talibán no nos causan problemas
las niñas vienen a educarse y yo estoy a
su servicio
la clase de religión ha terminado el
profesor de matemáticas ya bien
hola bienvenidas
cómo están estudiaron 2 ml
un hombre que enseña matemáticas a un
grupo de mujeres
una escena singular en territorio
talibán
bien voy a escribir operaciones en el
tablero y una por una las resolverán
por ejemplo la solución puede ser
encontrada con este método
y multiplicando por tres así
es igual
usaremos los dos métodos serán
aplicaremos el 5 por 2 encienden horas
de usar la camisa abanico
desde luego
hay muchas ideas falsas sobre los
talibanes ellos autorizan que tanto los
hombres como las mujeres estudien porque
ello beneficiará a las generaciones
futuras
nuestras generaciones han sido privadas
de educación hasta ahora debido a la
guerra
si las mujeres aprenden matemáticas y
ciencias podrían volverse ingenieras
economistas o profesoras con un discurso
aparentemente liberal pero en realidad
es poco probable que estas niñas vayan
algún día a la universidad cerca del 80%
de las afganas son analfabetas
en territorio talibán las pocas mujeres
graduadas vienen con frecuencia de las
grandes ciudades y son empleadas en los
centros de salud
como aquí en la clínica de omar hair
detrás de esta cortina se encuentra el
espacio reservado para las pacientes
el movimiento fundamentalista ha
aflojado un poco sus arcos sobre el
asunto de la salud femenina
estás enferma ventana
esta joven generalista formada en kabul
recibe pacientes que vienen de todo el
valle
hace 25 años sobrasada cat no habría
podido ejercer su profesión
hoy en día escucha y atiende a las
mujeres de talibanes
[Música]
no tengo apetito no he comido desde hace
dos días tienes problemas en casa sí qué
tipo de problemas no puedo tener hijos
tenía un bebé pero falleció de acuerdo
la familia política dice que el bebé
falleció por tu cuenta porque lo
llevaste donde tu padre
[Música]
búscala tarragona hijo de colono mueva
juanes zonas todas las mujeres afganas
tienen problemas psicológicos no sólo
aquí contaba hoy las mujeres sale un
poco incluso no se ven entre ellas
en este distrito en particular es cierto
que los habitantes viven en condiciones
muy difíciles
lleva el aborto y no tienen
distracciones de colima toma phone están
acá más sanos de servir una mera
me duele así
me duele hasta aquí son la seda cat es
una de las pocas doctoras que va y
vuelve desde la capital en la carretera
ni el ejército ni los talibán la
detienen
desde hace años existe una cooperación
tácita entre los dos enemigos para
facilitar los transportes médicos
y el día que llegue aquí los talibán
verificaron mi diploma universitario yo
leyeron con cuidado y confirmaron que
había ido a la universidad de kabul
luego me contrataron en kabul no tengo
burka pero aquí debo llevar la puesta
fuera de la sala de consulta es la
costumbre si no lo hiciera la gente
podría pensar que viene a motivar a las
mujeres para el desenfreno
cuando estaban en el poder durante los
años 90 los talibán les prohibían a los
afganos consultar a los médicos hombres
y les impedían el acceso a la salud
tiene contracciones de cuanto esta
dilatada la paciente hoy la autorizan al
doctora sin que asista a las enfermeras
en la clínica nadie está afiliado al
movimiento
abre tu mano es mejor que te ponga la
aguja en el brazo y los físicos edad 16
no se me hicieron contraer matrimonio
muy joven
[Aplausos]
y este es un noveno mes de embarazo es
el final de mi embarazo perfecta
la paciente va a tener su bebé y las
mujeres me pidieron que abandonara el
lugar con agua es que dicho mundo
pero si hay una urgencia vendrá a ayudar
al aparentar piedad se hace dentro de
esta comarca
dígales a las mujeres de su pueblo que
vengan al hospital para tener a sus
bebés
pero las mujeres prefieren quedarse en
casa
lo sé pero no está bien cuando ve a sus
familiares como un dique lees la
dirección del hospital y dígales todas
las cosas buenas que hacen los médicos
que trabajan ahí
calling the sweet
el bebé va bien es una niña
la paciente ya está vestida puede entrar
y como está bien verifique de nuevo su
tensión arterial los pagos
a
fuera de este santuario de las mujeres
son invisibles
el mercado de omar jail colinda con una
clínica
es el pulmón económico del pueblo un
mundo de hombres donde los talibán están
omnipresentes
sometidos a vigilancia constante todos
los civiles con los que hablamos los
adulan
como lo veremos con sign up y su padre
lleida vanidad
[__] lanza
sainz a que quieres un euro y es feroz
[Aplausos]
los talibán declaran que los alimentos
vencidos están prohibidos a la venta si
encuentran un alimento vencido nos
multan creo que es mejor vivir en
territorio talibán
matsa para qué
en los lugares gobernados por el estado
diga no no es posible desplazarse ni
mantener abiertos nuestros negocios en
la noche es muy peligroso aquí nuestro
negocio permanece abierto hasta las 20
horas y no tengo miedo
en cuanto a las mujeres pueden venir a
mi tienda así no estén acompañadas por
un hombre que vienen con la burka y los
talibanes no la detienen muchas de agost
durante nuestra grabación no vimos a
ninguna mujer en el mercado antes no
podíamos desplazar nuestras mercancías
desde la ciudad debido a la inseguridad
había que usar caminos desviados ahora
todo está calmado cuando los talibán
llegaron empezaron a motivarnos para ir
a las mezquitas nos enviaban cartas
firmadas por un jefe religioso diciendo
que debíamos avisarle si nuestros
vecinos y nuestros amigos no iban a la
mezquita entonces iban a verlos
[Música]
desde la legislación alimentaria hasta
la frecuencia de las oraciones los
talibán si me escuchan en todos los
aspectos de la vida cotidiana
se invitan al té en la sala de najibulá
sediqi este hombre nunca ha pertenecido
al movimiento pero un drama lo acercó a
los talibanes hace 8 años en las fuerzas
afganas y estadounidenses atacaron su
casa que antes no invitaba a los talibán
a tomar té en mi casa no me ocupaba de
la guerra no era partidario
nosotros los civiles sólo queríamos
estudiar es educar a nuestros hijos
ganar nuestro pan dar su mujer a los
soldados no mostrar su barbarie
sembraron el terror de combatir a los
talibán
los ataques venían del cielo eran bombas
y bombas y también ingresaron a nuestro
hogar tumbaron la puerta y destrozaron
todos los muebles de la casa eran tan
crueles abatieron a los niños durante su
sueño perdimos a cinco miembros de
nuestra familia todos eran niños o
estudiantes los talibán nacieron aquí
los conocemos viven en nuestras casas
nuestros pueblos nuestras comunidades y
no hemos vivido ninguna injusticia
causada por ellos
las fuerzas gubernamentales apoyadas por
el ejército estadounidense están
acusadas de ser las responsables de un
tercio de las víctimas civiles del
conflicto
como en el caso del padre de sign up
estos errores alimentan un resentimiento
que aprovechan los talibán
[Música]
afganistán es un país en esencia rural
los proyectos de desarrollo financiados
por la comunidad internacional no han
llegado a las zonas rurales pobres y muy
conservadoras
el vergel de mohamed verdad aquí sufre
por la sequía cada año
el auto de un amigo estos campos son
fértiles
pero no hay suficiente agua entonces se
vuelven secos ningún trabajo de
modernización ha sido llevado a cabo
aquí ningún tanque ha sido construido
debido a la guerra
estos son albaricoqueros pronto darán
frutas los manzanos no han florecido aún
vos
este año pudimos exportar nuestras
frutas a pakistán pero de costumbre las
vendemos sobre todo en kabul los talibán
no nos causan ningún problema por el
contrario me ayudan con el comercio aquí
en el emirato en los territorios
talibanes usted puede viajar sin miedo
tanto de día como de noche incluso con
dinero sabe los talibanes pertenecen a
estas zonas rurales saben cultivar la
tierra
cada año los talibán retienen un décimo
de las cosechas es el uzr un impuesto a
los agricultores uno de los numerosos
medios de financiación de sus
actividades
es un deber religioso yo dono entre
27.000 y 30.000 afganis al año por
concepto del user depende de nuestra
cosecha si las cosas van bien donó un
poco más
[Música]
30000 afganis el equivalente a 300 euros
una suma muy importante en un país en el
que la mitad de la población vive por
debajo del umbral de pobreza
[Música]
el monto del impuesto como todas las
leyes islámicas son establecidos en esta
mezquita
actualmente los dignatarios legislan con
base en prácticas que consideran
profanas como la música durante los
matrimonios
[Música]
las reporteras mujeres no pueden asistir
pero el traductor hombre pudo filmar
algunas imágenes de esta asamblea de
responsables religiosos y combatientes
hemos decidido todos los que no respeten
nuestras decisiones serán juzgados
en afganistán es lo que se llama el
gobierno de la sombra
paula uy salir es el gobernador talibán
del distrito uno de los ejecutivos de
este estado paralelo muy jerarquizado
era baja en el sitio
y uagr iban de la charia se aplica a
todo el mundo
tanto al simple ciudadano como al jefe
más poderosos cada lata es así ya
hacemos justicia y kim ya está llevar a
tajada alta hasta donde se extienda el
emirato talibán las vidas y los bienes
de las personas están seguros
tenemos escuelas programas agrícolas y
bodegas para almacenar frutas y verduras
he del time en este vídeo de audio
jasper de los cuales está su negativo
coreas de ratificar gravedad salió junio
de manu de paradores civil indica salud
y flores de vida cuando no tengamos
razón alguna para luchar en la guerra
terminará y desarrollaremos este país en
todos los ámbitos
jarque
el cava de esta nave está muy apurado
éste disminuyó
después del estudio de las leyes en la
asamblea judicial sesiona a cielo
abierto
en las zonas que controlan los talibán
pusieron en marcha tribunales de
justicia locales que arreglan
rápidamente asuntos comunes
la justicia gubernamental es percibida
como lenta y corrupta a pesar de miles
de millones de dólares gastados por la
comunidad internacional para su
funcionamiento es lo que explica en
parte de la popularidad de los
tribunales talibanes traiga los
expedientes y sus papeles
hoy tres hombres fueron convocados por
los jueces los dos primeros son
combatientes acusados de haber utilizado
sus armas por fuera de los combates
porque disparaste al aire
no sabía que estaba prohibido habla más
fuerte de acuerdo disparaste pero porque
era para celebrar un matrimonio si era
por un matrimonio haciendo eso y el arte
las reglas del emirato sabías
no sabía de estas reglas era nuevo en la
región y no estaba informado otra manera
de acuerdo pero habíamos difundido
comunicados oficiales a todos los jefes
del pueblo a ammán a santa jara de la
comisión de todas formas decidido es
armarte porque perturba este el orden
público a 120 dispara al aire está
prohibido asustar a nuestros habitantes
reconoces que insiste las reglas de la
inmediato talibán sólo si lo reconozco
porque disparaste porque mi amigo volvió
del frente
entonces disparaste para celebrar su
llegada
si no sabías que está prohibido disparar
al aire si estaba al tanto lo siento no
volveré a hacerlo
de acuerdo pero se decidió desarmarte a
esta nueva orden
allí venga aquí por favor el tercero
habría gastado mucho dinero para el
matrimonio de su hijo un exceso
contrario a la ley talibán
cuál es su apellido mi apellido es hai
pacha mire
sabe usted porque está frente a esta
comisión mi hijo es un combatiente
talibán y celebraba su compromiso
talibán pero tú no
sí pero celebraba el matrimonio de mi
hijo que es un talibán tercer talibán no
le da ningún derecho adicional al
contrario se expone a sanciones más
severas como yo debe ser sancionada más
severamente que los demás porque los
talibán tienen por misión hacer la yihad
por el amor a la entonces si en vez de
eso causan problemas o si no han
impedido que el mal se produzca deben
ser sancionados más duro o pocos de que
pague la fuerza y creerá si es cierto
hay testigos no lo niego pero sólo había
seis invitados pero del lado de la
familia política le surgieron a mi hijo
invitar a más gente más mujeres y mi
hijo estuvo de acuerdo yo no estuve
presente durante aquella conversación y
ahora me cae encima esto
y sé que debemos respetar la ley del
emirato talibán soy un adepto de este
emirato mi hijo ya es un combatiente
talibán y entonces veces todos
combatientes talibanes
acabamos de desarmar antes si se prueba
que infringe la ley y estoy dispuesto a
ser colgado en vez de una sanción más
clemente si estoy dispuesto pero con una
condición no ser acusado falsamente sin
pruebas de acuerdo seguiremos
investigando
aquí siendo la gente muy pobre cuando
planean un matrimonio gastan sumas por
encima de su capacidad hipoteca en su
tierra su jardín y se endeudan mucho
entonces los eruditos religiosos y los
combatientes talibanes del emirato
discutieron sobre el asunto para reducir
esos costos ya que en el islam en la
charía la extravagancia es un pecado
y los actos contrarios al islam deben
ser evitados
extra se detallarán de
esta justicia se dice equitativa para
los hombres
en cuanto a las mujeres los talibán
siguen haciendo las víctimas de su
crueldad
poco antes de nuestra llegada en zona
rural de edad donde tuvo lugar una parte
de nuestra grabación una joven fue la
tirada en público por un responsable
talibán
fue juzgada culpable del crimen de
indecencia tras haber hablado por
teléfono con un joven
[Música]
si esta mujer hubiese estado casada
corría el riesgo de lapidación por este
crimen
[Música]
pero el gobernador del distrito le
habría condenado a la misma suerte
actualmente como antes y la decisión de
los talibanes está en armonía con la ley
islámica
ya sea la lapidación a muerte ya la
decapitación o la amputación de la mano
[Música]
es un principio fuerte del islam es un
principio fuerte de la sharia
y no lo cambiaremos nunca hasta el
último juicio a camps como etiqueta que
mata puede tejer naranja
[Música]
abandonamos la atmósfera opresora del
pueblo con un sentimiento perturbado el
de haber encontrado una nueva generación
de talibán en cabeza de instituciones
casi funcionales pero donde la barbarie
no ha desaparecido
[Música]
los que no siguen sus preceptos no
tienen elección distinta que huir hacia
las ciudades para numerosas mujeres las
mas emancipadas es incluso un asunto de
sobrevivencia
la familia jalil y encontró el refugio
en un barrio tranquilo de la ciudad de
edad
masud a la madre dirigía una escuela
para niñas en guardián un distrito rural
conquistado por los talibán hace dos
meses
cuando hablamos de rojo
ella solía ser de oye nada más
este libro habla del amor que le tenemos
a nuestras madres y yo amo ese tema
fue la noche cuando mi mamá vino a verme
y me dijo que algo había ocurrido en la
escuela hubo un atentado suicida en
plena noche los hombres trataron de
hacer explotar la escuela mi mamá vino a
verme y me dijo que no podíamos vivir
más ahí me dijo ahora atacan las
escuelas debemos irnos a herat y vivir
en la ciudad yo mis amigos mis animales
y mis montañas me hacen falta
desde que se exilió en la ciudad más
suda permanece en contacto con sus
antiguas vecinas otras mujeres de
guardián que como ella huyeron cuando
llegaron los talibanes
[Música]
de traje pasteles con azúcar es tan
gentil de tu parte déjame traerte un
plato
sohail up shade es una de ellas la joven
viuda confeccionaba postres en el pueblo
para hacer vivir a su familia
la seguridad es verdaderamente mala en
coreano sabes que hubo violentos
combates anoche dispararon un mortero
sobre la escuela de causar si es mejor
estar triste aquí que vivir allá en este
momento
mis hijos que se quedaron en guardia no
hacen falta mi profesora durante 19 años
allá y desde hace 2 años era la
directora de la escuela todas las niñas
del pueblo eran mis alumnas algunas se
volvieron médicas
tuve que salir porque recibí amenazas
porque trabajaba para una escuela para
volcar el día anterior a nuestra partida
o combates muy violentos mi marido dijo
que no podíamos quedarnos que si no nos
mataban hoy nos mataría mañana
y estos pasteles logras vender lo que
cocinas aquí no aquí en el mercado nadie
los compra en el pueblo engordan era
empleada de una panadería mi trabajo me
gustaba y las ventas iban bien en mi
pueblo éramos un grupo de diez o doce
mujeres que trabajábamos pero recibimos
siempre amenazas tiraron papeles con
advertencias en los lugares en los que
entregábamos nuestros pasteles le
repetían al jefe del pueblo que iban a
cerrar el local donde preparábamos
nuestros pasteles que iban a golpearlo
con un mortero debido a ello las mujeres
tuvieron miedo y abandonaron el trabajo
el dinero que ganábamos entre la mañana
y la noche no estaba orgullo después de
eso tuvimos que permanecer en casa y
esperar a que los hombres del pueblo
decidieran sobre nuestra vida
hola fácil todo esto porque vendíamos
nuestros dulces a los mercados
tengo fotos de mi cumpleaños
muéstrame en tu teléfono
esta vida está detrás de nosotros
nuestras casas y nosotros estamos aquí
eran buenos tiempos
y el jardín mira mira este es el jardín
si los niños serán libres allá
había columpios jugaban con ellos veo me
hace falta la gente mis vecinos la
escuela las calles no hay más mala
suerte que la de los afganos no crees
nadie en el mundo cambiaría su vida por
la de nosotros ni una hora
desde hace 40 años tanto en la ciudad
como en zona rural los afganos lloran
sus muertos
más de un millón de víctimas llegadas
por una guerra sin fin
con el retiro de las tropas occidentales
y el avance talibán el futuro del país
se anuncia bastante sombrío
[Música]
en este escenario de lo peor hay una
frágil esperanza la paz reencontrada
entre hermanos afganos
más chico y muchas de ayudar
[Música]
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
reporteros el documental de frances 24
los espero en una próxima oportunidad la
próxima
[Música]